let's get some practice taking sums of
infinite geometric series so we have one
over here and just to make sure that
we're dealing with the geometric series
let's make sure we have a common ratio
so let's see to go from the first term
to the second term we multiply by one
third and then go to the next term we
are going to multiply by one third again
and we're going to keep doing that so we
can rewrite the series as
plus
8 times one-third
eight times
one-third
plus
plus eight times one-third squared
eight times
one-third squared each successive term
we multiply by 1 3 again
and so when you look at it this way
you're like okay we could write this in
sigma notation this is going to be equal
to so this the first thing we wrote is
equal to this which is equal to this is
equal to the sum
the sum and we could start at 0 or at 1
depending on how we'd like to do it we
could say from k
is equal to 0 and this is an infinite
series right here we're just going to
keep on going forever
so 2 infinity of
well what's our first term our first
term is 8
so it's going to be 8 times our common
ratio
times our common ratio 1 3 to the k
to the k power and let me just verify
that this indeed works and i always do
this just as a reality check and i
encourage you to do the same so when k
equals 0 that should be the first term
right over here you get 8 times 1 3 to
the 0 power which is indeed 8. when k is
equal to 1 that's going to be our second
term here that's going to be 8 times 1 3
to the first power that's what we have
here and so when k is equal to a 2 that
is this term right over here so these
these are all describing the same thing
so now that we've seen that we can write
a geometric series in multiple ways
let's find the sum
well we've seen before
and we prove it in other videos if you
have a sum from k equals 0 to infinity
and you have your first term
a
times r to the k power
r
to the k power assuming this converges
so assuming that the absolute value of
your common ratio is less than one this
is what you need needs to be true for
convergence this is going to be equal to
this is going to be equal to our first
term
which is a
over
1 minus our common ratio
1 minus our common ratio and if this
looks unfamiliar to you i encourage you
to watch the video where we uh where we
find the form we derive the formula for
the sum of an infinite geometric series
but just applying that over here we are
going to get
we are going to get this is going to be
equal to our first term
which is eight
so that is eight
over
one minus
one
minus our common ratio
over
one-third and we know this is going to
converge because our common ratio the
the magnitude the absolute value of
one-third is indeed less than one and so
this is all going to converge to
this is going to converge to
eight
over
one minus one third is two thirds
two thirds which is the same thing as
eight times three halves which is let's
see this could become you divide eight
by two that becomes four and so this is
this will become
12.